andré courrèges lors d'un récent
dossiers de l'écran pierre balmain vous
a comparé une compétence est ce que les
pompes à essence se vendent bien
je crois que les sens quand même cela
remet très bien mais je n'ai pas voulu
lui répondre parce que j'aurais pu lui
dire aussi que lui il représente le type
tout à fait complet du danseur argentin
des années 1930 mais ce serait mal
tourné andré courrèges dans ce salon du
prêt-à-porter ça correspond à quoi
eh bien ça correspond à une porte
ouverte sur la vie premièrement j'ai des
lignes de diffusion qui s'appelle
couture futur et hyperbole qui sont
faits pour descendre pour aller vers la
cliente clientes françaises clientes
internationale à des prix compétitifs et
je les présente dont ici mais ce qui
m'intéresse à moi c'est cette porte
ouverte sur la vie sur les confrères sur
les propositions différentes sur
l'animation qui lie à ici en tant que
mannequin en métal commandes mode
françaises européennes et
internationales
et ça fait quelque chose qui est
formidable
on regarde ce que nous avons pu
découvrir deux des modèles que nous
avons pu voir
nous avons l'impression soit à travers
le prêt-à-porter internationale la
boutique où le luxe que la mode a
raccourci donc une fois de plus henri
crohas j'avais raison et à peut-être
toujours
oui je pense que tout le monde se rallie
après avoir fait un petit détour inutile
mais c'est la vie et et je crois que
maintenant il faudrait pas qu'ils
exagèrent qui raccourcissent mme de trop
parce que ça serait encore au détriment
du service que l'on doit faire en tant
que le couturier créateur c'est
d'embellir la femme et que cette femme
en définitive soit une conquête de
l'homme
donc on doit lui laisser sa féminité et
son importance vis-à-vis de l'homme la
féminité nous allons pouvoir si vous le
voulez bien juger sur pièce si je puis
m'exprimer ainsi
avec deux gros modèles voici deux de mes
modèles comme modèle à ce futuriste
c'est un collant avec une petite veste
en vinyle sans manches pourquoi parce
que c'est beaucoup plus logique
voulait enlever 10 pts voilà c'est un
poulain c'est une sorte de deuxième peau
mais qui est très fonctionnel basket il
se des graphes complètement
vous êtes extrêmement pratique c'est
très pratique je pense que c'est ce que
les femmes porteront dans quelques
années lorsque l'ambiance le permettra
la liberté de mouvement
bon ici c'est un modèle très apparemment
très classique qui est deux sortes de
combinaisons cours
andré courrèges nous évoquons tout à
l'heure cette mode un peu folle folle au
sens irraisonnée de ce mot le long le
milan j'ai l'impression que cette mode
là a fait beaucoup de mal
oui beaucoup de mal au prêt-à-porter à
son industrie oui elle a fait mal et sur
le plan industriel commercial et même
sur le plan psychologique la femme de la
femme au niveau de la fram au niveau de
l'homme et il est temps de reprendre un
pro le problème avec une notion plus
sérieuse de ce qu'est la mission du
créateur au regard des modèles que vous
nous présentez on s'aperçoit d'une chose
c'est le très large la très large
couverture l'éventail fantastique de
clientèle que vous pouvez avoir
car dans le fond je 22 18 ou 19 ans peut
s'habiller avec au modèle mais aussi une
femme de 40 ans le bien sûr parce que
j'ai des différentes lignes et
différents prix je peux vous avouer que
je ne vends que le dise le dixième le
10e ce que je pourrais vendre parce que
ma fabrication ne suis pas un
en définitive un dixième de fabriquer et
10/10 de possibilité de vendre deux
modèles à nouveau le noise elle
c'est un petit blouson sombrer
sur une robe extrêmement simple
mais c'est minime
et je ne savais qu'un phénomène peu de
femmes osent rentrer chez courrèges en
se disant mais les prix peut-être d'une
maison de couture sont très chers je
crois qu'on va insister sur les prix
pour présider beaucoup de gens se pense
que haute couture veux dire très cher
mais dans ma tête mes différentes gammes
comme par exemple c'est sous une robe du
soir un manteau
qui sont faites en coton trenet est très
léger pour l'été et bien sûr c'est une
gamme de tout ce que vous avez vu qui
navigue entre 300 et 500
parce que je veux une accroche jeunes et
les jeunes n'ont pas beaucoup de pouvoir
d'achat mais ça n'empêche pas qu'une
femme de 40 ans peut porter ça et même
plus j'habille des femmes beaucoup plus
âgés qui sont jeunes d'esprit
tout ça c'est des faux problèmes qu'il
faut complètement déblayer